so for this video I need to explain the
abandoned plot lines because showing you
these scenes without saying anything out
of context won't really work if I forget
any plot lines that just shows how
forgettable they are so you can just
comment them below and I'll pin a
comment and keep updating it with like
all the plot lines I forgot to put into
the video so for the first abandoned
plot line let's look into light and that
sword shall be Lightbringer in this case
she's referring to Stannis Baratheon
because he pulls out Lightbringer she
believes that he's a Zora hi but that
doesn't really pan out Lightbringer is a
part of the azure high prophecy and none
of the other main characters ever
Poehler start out of the fire instead
she just lights a bunch of Dothraki
swords wow I've always hated the bells
they ring fahara
if the city surrenders they will ring
the bells and raise the gates please if
you hear them ringing the bells call off
the attack I've never known bells to
mean surrender
so yeah they kind of abandoned the whole
notion that the bells are meant for
horror even random people of King's
Landing are saying ring the bells
[Music]
who are you oh no one but she is the
mother of dragons she needs true
protectors now more than ever I bet a
lot of you forgot about the master in
Qarth who basically gives her all the
answers it's never explained as to how
she knows everything the thief you seek
is with her now she's basically just
used as a plot device to tell Jorah
where the dragons are the king will have
20 children you have three that doesn't
make sense gold will be backgrounds so
in the show it doesn't say how Cersei
will die in this prophecy the part of
the prophecy that is wrong however is
the amount of children she has in the
first season when Cersei is talking to
lady Catelyn after bran falls out of the
window she talks about her first kid who
passed away I lost my first boy a
black-haired beauty he was a fighter too
tried to beat the fever that took him I
don't know if this technically counts as
an abandoned plot line but the prophecy
is still wrong you I can't talk here him
true heir to the Iron Throne the whole
impact of John being a Targaryen was to
just have conflict from Danny and John's
relationship there is really no other
development that came from it by the end
of the season is practically just
forgotten that John is a Targaryen any
[__] off and goes north of the
wildlings so this is a pretty
straightforward plotline that was
abandoned the one annoying thing is that
they have bran who is omniscient and
knows everything and none of the
characters ask brand what the symbols
mean they literally have a character
that can spell out any exposition they
want and it would make sense but they
just don't use an ox also the night king
really wants to get down south what he
stops and takes the time to do this
this white Walker region never comes up
again and maybe there are more white
walkers there also the whole baby thing
doesn't get barred up by Brent or has
ever revisited it is assumed that they
grow up to be white walkers but they
could have easily shown this in one of
brand's visions just just me read in
general she says she's gonna go protect
her family from the white Walker attack
and she never ends up coming back for
the Battle of Winterfell Stennis was not
the prince who was promised that someone
has to be I brought up Lightbringer
earlier but I'll make an actual point
for the prince who has promised the last
time it was really mentioned was just in
season seven
pulsus mm yeah there's not two thousand
horses they're all the hype that they
were gonna be a cool badass army in
season seven kind of gets ruined that's
disappointing three to four seasons of
faceless training and this is the last
time that she uses that ability she even
brings a bunch of face masks with her to
Winterfell that she never uses you'll
never walk again but you will fly I
guess this line only applies to Ravens
when it's been proven that brand can
warg into other things his abilities
just aren't used in the later seasons so
it just feels like the whole plot ride
was abandoned and now he just kind of
stares at people this kind of goes in to
the last point but brand can interact
with the past this could have had so
much potential but nothing is made of it
after the Hodor seen maybe Brian was the
voices inside of the mad Kings head that
drove him crazy but nothing has really
ever made of this plot phone dardo is
basically abandoned so there would be
space for Jon Snow everyone thought he
would infiltrate the golden company but
that never happens remind them what
happened when Daenerys Stormborn and her
dragons came to Meereen
the entire plot in Essos is left behind
and there is no update given as to its
state after Danny passes away they could
very well just have turned back to
normal and slavers are back in control
Robin Arryn was abandoned after sanso
left her bail it would have made more
sense he'd be showed up at the bow of
the bastards with this guy and actually
became a character in Winterfell while
preparing for the long night instead of
showing up at the end looking all
and normal well the enjoyed being
eunuchs I found this out on reddit but
this guy on the right has a pretty big
bulge last time I was here you killed my
son with wildfire he then drops out
immediately by saying this there's a
path to the left that hopes the cliff
God hardly ever come forward and that
was the only time at Davos ever brought
up that Tyrion killed his son this makes
for a pretty massive conflict but it's
never explored so David and Dan forgot
about the whole moment where Jamie tries
to kill Danny she would have remembered
this moment and during the trial of
Jaime in Winterfell she would have
definitely sentenced him to death you
can make the argument that Danny didn't
recognize him but if she was half smart
she would have put together that an
officer on a horse with a golden hand 15
feet away from her is Jaime Lannister
after the Battle of Winterfell the whole
Lord of Light plotline is dropped we
don't get any answers and the only thing
that the Lord of Light did was just
resurrect people it just felt like cheap
plot armor and barely any questions were
answered about the Lord of Light the
last point in the whole like lord of the
light story is MOA saundra turning into
a [__] fart cloud
[Music]
there's not much for me to really go
into here David and Dan didn't explain
the magic at all and it just happens for
the sake of having magic as a fantasy
album or they even tweeted about how
they wanted to downplay that element if
you want to read the whole tweet you can
just pause it
so after L aureus and dyes stored kind
of just turns to dust and fades into the
background never to be mentioned again
except during the scene the new Prince
of Dorne fetches his support dorm
pledged their support but they didn't
show up to the battle of King's Landing
the Prince of Dorne just shows up at the
ending meeting half-asleep and basically
just doesn't say the Dothraki just
disappear after Danny dies Johnson would
technically be our new call since he
killed Danny
the only reaction to Rickon stark dying
is John staring at his corpse for a
solid six seconds Sansa doesn't even
bring up that her brother dies and they
don't even throw a funeral for him after
the battle Arya Stark also comes back to
Winterfell she doesn't mean to ask about
Rick on his completely abandoned him
after he died
so Searcy blow up the Septon killed like
a thousand people when she has named the
new queen you can see how dissatisfied
and mad everyone is at her and this
never comes up again they are grateful
for your protection within the walls of
the red key
what do you mean grateful for their
protection if she blew up this up to
dodge a court trial what do you think
she'll do if she loses she has a keen
sense of poetic justice that [__]
fanny Searcy clearly wants to kill her
brothers by contracting one of the best
sell swords later on Cersei has the
option to kill Tyrion but doesn't
because of that hot plot armor
so Sam doesn't bring up how his best
friend left him to die
that would seem pretty betraying but
they don't go there if it's a boy I want
to name him John also Sam is going to
name his next kid John what about my boy
ed who literally sacrificed himself to
save Sam he knows you're here come for
[Music]
the knight King is clearly holding her
neck and she doesn't get a single mark
from it this also counts for a point
where Arya forgets to just be an
assassin and she screams with a knight
King so he turns her on to catch her I
wouldn't take it look maybe they're
trying to curry some favor with the new
master of coin have you ever known a
[__] to turn down gold they were happy
enough to take it when I gave it to them
what did you tell him
I take your two best men and lead them
through the back streets which I know
well and open the front gate in comes
the army that was for Yong Chi and this
one is for marine the nurses whole
attack strategy back then was to
stealthily infiltrate cities and take
them down from the inside they could
have easily done this for King's Landing
because the Tyrian does the city inside
and out where they keep the dragon
skulls I need the red Jeep take her down
there
keep following the stairway is down down
as far as they'll go you'll come out
onto a beach at the foot of the keep a
dinghy we'll be waiting for you
so for whatever reason Tyrion doesn't
tell Danny about the hidden entrance and
instead she goes crazy and destroys the
city Ellen page's disappears after
season one and Arya's revenge towards
them is dropped in pain I can't sleep
until I say the names then arias whole
Kilis gets heavily downplayed and
instead is contracted to kill the night
king there is not much of a point to
this scene the show brings back
nightmares only to show her again and
not bring back her pack during the
Battle of Winterfell this is one of the
last scenes where Varys was actually
being masterful at manipulation and
being a
spy you did conspire to kill the Queen's
soldiers we both know the penalty for
that crime
how will poor Dom get on without his
mother and with his breathing problem I
tell you anything they'll kill me after
this he basically just becomes a
messenger for Danny and he also becomes
the opposite of a spy by telling
everyone that he's committing treason
you heard a voice call out from the
flames do you remember this isn't a
major point but we never find out what
the words Varys heard in the flames when
he became a eunuch should I tell you the
name of the one who spoke everyone is
what they are and where they are for a
reason also we don't really know what
happens to the red priests after the
long night the Lord of lights whole
objective was to kill the night king so
what happens to the other priests did
they just go on retirement beerus
informed half of Westeros about Jon
being a Targaryen but none of the other
Lords ever really bring that up he's met
our prisoners it is not over until the
Queen's enemies are defeated and much
more defeated do you want them to be
there on their knees they are breathing
if grey worm was killing Lannisters who
surrendered then he would definitely
kill Jon for killing Danny
Cersei throughout the show is always
scheming and being productive it even
follows her point of view on multiple
occasions and this gets trottin season 8
and all she does is stare at windows
what they see is just the end of the
Dothraki essentially how far good
the Scorpion symbol is regal and then
the episode after they can't hit [__]
although this is at the very end we
never find out where drug on takes Dany
and what happens to drug on and drug on
any word he was last spotted flying east
rather away the better perhaps I can
find him
they just immediately dropped this I can
never be Lord of Winterfell I can never
be Lord of anything in the three-eyed
raven will you lead the Seven Kingdoms
to the best of your abilities from this
day until your last day why do you think
I came all this way so yeah that's all
the plot lines that I could find and
come up with I wanted to make one big
video that grouped all of them together
if you have any other ones that I forgot
then comment it below and have a good
day